[Music]
we all know how important this upcoming
election is in 130 days you will get to
decide the future of this great country
former Speaker of the House and Fox News
contributor Newt Gingrich is out with a
brand new book it's titled Trump and the
American future solving the great
problems of our time Newt spoke with
Sean earlier this week to discuss the
impacts of this election and how it
could fundamentally change America have
a look we were talking on radio this
week we're talking about how we first
met in 1990 and a host and you were
doing a speech in Decatur Alabama and
you came on and and our history is I got
to emcee that the night you took back
Congress for the Republicans in the
first time in 40 years I know we say it
a lot and it's been true but not as true
as it is now I believe if Joe Biden the
socialist agenda the new Green Deal
week foreign policy is implemented
America becomes unrecognizable and I
don't think there's a way to recover
that's how crucial this election is okay
I think this is the most important
election since Abraham Lincoln in 1860
so 160 years is a long time but Elton is
just Biden I think it's the Machine of
Biden Pelosi and Schumer and what the
three of them would do the minute they
had real power the people they would
appoint they'd immediately repeal all of
Trump's executive orders I think they
would do everything they could in the
very first year to turn America into
California to impose left-wing values on
all of our schools to reinforce for the
big Internet companies that they should
eliminate all conservatives like I truly
think it would be a catastrophic well
that should outcome if you ended up with
Biden Pelosi and Schumer in charge of
America so let's assume the third
quarter of July August
bird numbers we're already seeing I
didn't think we see growth numbers this
fast based on the economy shutting down
but we're seeing them so let's assume we
have a half of e recovery which would be
unprecedented job growth in this country
and the one of the great American
comeback success stories let's assume
that some of these deep state operatives
that plotted against Donald Trump are
probably indicted let's assume that Joe
Biden at some point has to come out of
his basement and and I know that's gonna
you know her Terry McAuliffe was fine
for him to stay down there forever and
that he's actually going to have to talk
and explain his record and you know I
don't think it's gonna he's gonna do
particularly well but that's just me
looking into my little you know crystal
ball how does this election then fall
out in your view because it's hard you
got to win you know Florida Ohio North
Carolina Georgia Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Michigan you know it's you gotta you
gotta literally run the table if you're
a Republican no you know I don't think
so I've been active as you know for a
very long time I lived through the 72
campaign with Nixon crushing McGovern I
lived through the 84 campaign I was a
activist congressman in San Francisco at
the Democratic convention after Walter
Mondale I have been through a series
these things I was with George HW Bush
when he was behind Dukakis by 19 points
that was in May he beat him by eight
points in November which meant that one
out of every four Americans switch their
vote in that period so I think one or
two things is going to happen if Trump
makes a reasonable economic recovery not
factor where we were but clearly moving
in that direction
and if he draws a clear contrast not
just with white but with Pelosi Schumer
and Biden as a machine because that's
much scarier than just Mike I think at
that point I don't think it'll be close
I think will win by a huge margin let's
just
thank you you usually write a great I'm
gonna cling to your hope because if you
it's nothing but the future of our whole
Republic at stake nothing serious but
congratulations on the book thank you